- I know you like jazz,
but you look like rock and roll, man.
You're so cool. - Oh, thank you.
Well coming from you, high praise indeed.
- I'm just saying--
- You look fantastic. - Oh thank you.
- Hey, I never noticed these tattoos before.
- I have fifteen.
- You do? (audience cheering)
- Don't tell my mom.
- You think... Do you think I have...
- No, it's addictive.
- Really? Should I... Do you think I have any tattoos?
- I would say no.
- Why?
- I don't know. You seem like you'd be like,
"That feels like forever, and that's probably a bad idea."
(audience laughing)
Which it is sometimes.
But then you just change your tattoos.
- I guess so.
You are so great.
Let me look at you.
- Oh thanks, these are my country boots.
- You are so great, and I so respect
everything you are and what you do.
- Oh thank you.
- I just love you to pieces. (audience cheering)
- Thank you. We haven't seen each other since
we played Hollywood Game Night.
Yes, and I scared everyone.
(laughs)
- Not me, you were great. - Yeah.
- You were vivacious, you were fantastic.
- I was very into it.
- You were a force of nature.
- You got stuck between me and Jennifer Garner.
We were both beasts!
- You were both full of beans.
You were great.
But, Richard Curtis, who does those is great.
It's a very - - Yeah, Red Nose Day.
- Beautiful, yeah.
It's a very - he raises lots and lots of money
and helps people in a very wonderful way.
- I know he started in the UK and he came over here
and I've been a part of it a couple times
and it's a really cool,
it's a way to have fun and see celebrities
make an idiot of themselves,
and you raise money for kids.
It's really cool.
- You know, yeah, it's really cool.
You know how I know him?
He wrote the script, you know,
he did "Four Weddings and a Funeral",
- Yes. - And "Notting Hill".
- "Love Actually".
- And "Love Actually".
His first movie that he wrote was "The Tall Guy".
That was me, I was the tall guy.
(audience laughs)
And, Emma Thompson, was her first movie, Emma Thompson.
- I love Emma! - It was a love story.
Yeah, Look up "Tall Guy".
Yeah, I love her, too.
- Oh, yeah, that's -
Okay, I haven't seen that one!
- Yeah, no.
It was a long time ago.
- I love Richard Curtis.
Both of us have a lot in common.
I was reading your pre-interview notes.
Like, okay, we have kids around the same age,
and both have kids named River.
We love sunflowers, we're into music,
we're both thespians.
I'm just kidding, I can't act.
(audience laughs)
- You're a very good actor.
- I am not, and I hate it.
But, I do!
No, we have both kids named River.
That's random.
Yours is a boy, right?
- Yes!
I love River for a girl, too.
I love androgynous names. - Me too.
- Yeah, River.
Hi, River! - I mean, right?
Those curls! - Look at that.
Wait a minute.
Now those are boys.
Those are two boys.
- I know, but the curls are great!
- All the time, people go, "Oh, I love your daughters."
(audience laughs)
- I knew they were sons.
- Okay, because we have them cut their hair.
Look at that, that's River there.
- I love it!
- Oh my gosh,
And that's Charlie Ocean, and that's River Joe.
- Charlie ocean is the coolest.
You have the coolest kid names.
Where did you get Charlie Ocean?
- Uh, num, num, num, num.
I don't know. (audience laughs)
- You're known around these parts.
Like, everybody heard you were coming here
and all the ladies, they call you a "zaddy".
Do you know what a "zaddy" is?
- Not exactly.
- Well, I actually don't either.
- No.
- Like, I didn't know what a "zaddy" was either.
So, I had to get someone from my staff to tell us.
So, Kayla, where are you at?
- Over here!
- Kayla's over there.
- I see her.
- Kayla, what makes Jeff a "zaddy"?
What's a "zaddy"?
- Well, for whatever reason, Kelly,
kids today feel like being a dad is lame for some reason.
They think dad jokes are lame,
dad jeans are lame.
But, the fact of the matter is,
there's nothing lame about being a dad.
And a "zad" is a man who might
be a little bit more seasoned,
but still has that youthful zest, youthful zeal.
That's where that "z" is coming from.
And Jeff is a prime example of this.
I mean, check out this fit.
Y'all have seen his Instagram.
Zaddy all day long.
(audience cheers) - Yes!
A "zaddy"!
- I don't know.
- So, it's kind of like a "MILF"?
Is that what that is, for like women?
Or is that not daytime?
You probably can't say that.
You can't say that on daytime, Jeff.
That's just crude.
- Eh, yeah.
- That's crude. - I apologize.
I'm so sorry.
- I mean, how did you come here and just,
say those references.
- I don't know how I can make it up to you.
I'm sorry.
- What do you think about being a "zaddy"?
- I don't know.
I like being a daddy.
- He's like, "I'm still trying to
"understand the definition."
That's me too.
- I think I get it.
I think it's complimentary.
- It is very complimentary.
- Thank you very much. - Yes.
- But I like being a daddy.
That opened up a whole new world.
- It is such a cool world!
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, I thought I loved my life,
and then I had kids.
Being pregnant with them was horrible,
but afterwards, great!
Yeah.
- I want to hear about all of that, but I saw,
I've been watching the show,
I saw your kids on the show,
when they came out and ran to you and hugged you.
I started to get weepy just seeing it.
They're so cute, could they be cuter?
- My daughter is more,
yeah, my daughter is definitely,
I'm going to have to like,
I'm going to have to Kendrick Lamar, humble that one down.
- Really?
- Yeah, she's so,
I love it, she's bold,
but she's never met a stranger
and definitely loves attention.
- Really?
- I don't know where she gets it from, Jeff.
- Molds from all the artists I do the grill for.
- Wait a minute, wait a minute.
- Yeah, this is her teeth.
- Whose teeth?
- Beyonce.
- That's Beyonce's teeth?
- Yeah.
- This is Beyonce's teeth!
- I did a grill for her, so.
- Hey, She's got little tiny teeth.
- Tiny. - Look how tiny.
Well, she's a delicate creature.
Look at my big horse teeth compared.
- My teeth are gigantic.
- They're excellent.
Look at those chompers! - Welcome back!
I'm here with Jeff Goldblum!
(audience cheers)
I feel like I have big teeth.
- You have perfect sized teeth.
- I think I have big teeth.
- And look at them,
and look how sparkly and white and perfect.
- They are.
I have the little Madonna gap, too.
- It's perfect!
- That's what I call it.
The Madonna gap, because I feel cooler
because she has one.
- Really? - Yeah.
I don't know if she wants it to be called that.
- I like that game.
- I wanted to talk about your show!
- Let's talk about the show.
- Let's talk about your show.
Because your show is awesome!
It's such a cool idea,
"The World According to Jeff Goldblum",
and tell everybody what the, kind of,
premise of it is.
- Well, it's on Disney Plus,
and we kind of, and we did,
they just, by the way, renewed us
for a second season. - Nice!
(audience cheers)
- It's the first time I'm mentioning it publicly.
- Oh yeah!
- I found out today!
- That's so exciting!
- I found out today.
We're going to do a bunch more this next year.
I had a great time shooting them.
They are me, following, you know,
familiar objects, like flowers,
- Or coffee, - Or coffee, we did.
We did sneakers, barbecues, RV's,
cosmetics, jewelry, different things.
- Just every day things. - Swimming pools.
Yeah, every day things.
But we find the interesting,
complicated surprising things about them,
and then I move in and out of
the aficionados on the subject
and have an experience.
It may give way to my personal associations,
and my personal epiphany or revelation of some kind.
And also, some facts about them that may be interesting.
And some abstractions, and larger ideas.
What do you think of that?
- That was a lot! That was a lot.
So wait, what is something that's kind of amazed you?
- Well, there's been amazing things.
You saw, in that clip, you saw us go to Texas.
We were in Houston at Johnny Dang's Grill Emporium.
- Sounds about right.
- Like those people, they gave me a grill.
They made a grill for me.
I have a grill that I didn't wear today,
but I have a grill.
- I got a grill.
- Did you post a picture of it?
- I think there's been a picture of it, yeah.
- Oh my!
And then, I like the one where
you got to get in a pool.
- So, - Like, yeah.
- Yes.
So, I got into, I went to Raging Waters.
There were, I got into a sensory deprivation pool.
But I also went to Texas.
I went to Houston to the NASA Neutral Buoyancy Lab
and where there's the largest pool there
so that they can practice,
because the astronauts,
whom I met a couple of them,
and women who are at the end of their training,
are going to be astronauts.
They can go in the pool for like six hours at a time
in all their stuff,
because at the bottom of it,
there's a replica of the International Space Station.
- I love your show!
That's so interesting.
- I do too.
- Yeah, it's so cool! Yeah.
Okay, I have a question though,
because I saw you perform on Hollywood Game Night
and you said, "Oh yeah, I work with this band,"
and so, where did "Mildred Snitzer Orchestra" come from?
Because that's pretty specific.
- It's unusual.
Because you're trying to come up with a name for your band.
- We are trying to come up with a name for my band.
- Maybe we can help her in the next two minutes.
How we came up with our thing was,
there was a lady who lived near us in Pittsburgh,
where I grew up,
and she was a friend of my mom's, Shirley.
Her name was Mildred Snitzer.
So, when we had to do it,
I said, "Hey, that's an interesting name."
She was a great lady too.
She lived to be 100.
- I love how you're like, "And your name is my band."
(laughs)
- What?
Well, I did.
She lived to be 104,
and we liked it,
so I said Mildred Snitzer Orchestra.
- 104?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She was great.
- Wow!
I love it!
- How about your band?
What are going to call your band?
- Well, the fans so far online,
my favorite one is,
because every time I say,
"Give it up for my band, y'all!"
And so, they call them "My Band, Y'all".
- "My Band, Y'all".
- "My Band, Y'all", that's my favorite so far.
That's okay.
That may not survive the choice.
- It's not as cool as "Mildred Snitzer".
I'm aware.
- Well, I like that.
Well, if you have an interesting person
who was a friend, or whose name you like,
you could call it that.
- Hmm.
I have very basic friend names.
Yeah.
- How about, hey, but you're going to go to Las Vegas
and kind of- - I am.
- Be doing your thing.
I just came back from Las Vegas.
- Yes, I love it.
- How about, Kelly,
do you think it'll be "Kelly Clarkson and the something"?
- "And My Band, Y'all".
- Oh, yeah.
So maybe, "Kelly Clarkson and the Wayne Newton Orchestra".
- "The Wayne Newton Orchestra"!
- Or the Danny Gans.
You know Danny Gans?
- (laughs) No.
- He was the entertainer of the year for many years.
Right, "Danny Gans Orchestra".
But, we were just talking.
- I want a cool name.
- Well, just in conversation,
when you find yourself talking,
just today, I was talking to Inara George,
our great singer who you'll see in a second.
And she was saying, "Oh I couldn't go to,
"my husband's taking care of the kids today,
"and he's on the gardening committee,"
- "Gardening Committee", that's a good band.
- I said, "That's a good band name."
- "Gardening Committee".
- "Gardening Committee", but how about,
your initials are "KC".
- Yeah, And the Moonshine Band.
- How about "KC"-
That's what we thought.
"KC and the Moonshine Band".
Or "KC and the Sun Burnt Band".
- Uh, well, that's it.
That's all I have.
How about "KC at the Bat", you know.
- I'm going to be honest with you,
my favorite is "Gardening Committee".
(laughs)
- I like it.
That's yours. "Gardening Committee".
Take it.
- That's it! He's done it!
He's done it again.